[Music]
you said something important that it is
being honored by your peers here and
that we have each other we do indeed how
important it's absolutely vital it's
vital to our survival you know to our
forward movement you know I mean no no
man is alone no woman is alone don't
believe that you know don't believe in
that we have each other reach out to one
another and Courtney talked about this
being your season but we talk about
wakanda and we see Ryan coogler there
and we see you doing 9-1-1 and all these
things what does it mean to be working
at this high level to be the queen in
essence at this point in oh my gosh I
need to sit down somewhere
and fan myself oh my God it's it's
amazing because it's been it's been
Decades of a career and and to remain to
be able to do and persevere at a high
level and for it to be appreciated and
to receive so much love and support you
know from audiences from my community
um you know from around the world it's
great oh my gosh I only wish my mother
could see it be here to witness it
woman King was trending number one for
seven days on Netflix people are
watching it like crazy I just want to
know your thoughts as you watch all the
love that people are giving to this
movie
except for a certain group of people in
a certain Academy which I have a problem
with
when I hear all of that I the only word
I can think of is deserved yes the
artists that were involved in the making
of the woman king and the reaction from
the audience as as proven that it is
what you would call a great piece of
cinematic art so I think it's deserved
it's a great piece of cinematic art it
is great acting and you also have great
action and it is you see females giving
you this and telling a story that hasn't
been told how important was it to tell
that story and now to see the way that
people both black and white are
responding to this story and learning
history at a time where history is being
erased you know the thing about Legacy
is legacy is not always about buildings
and changing a street name sometimes
Legacy is about leaving something in
people and the thing that needs to be
left in people is that we're worthy and
that we're seeing and that and that we
are capable
and I think that that's one of the
reasons why we want to make woman King
you know to see black women leading a
global box office and a story that was a
seven-year Journey yes to get it done
and it's done beautifully and we're so
proud of it
foreign